so the lincoln project has accused rudy
giuliani of defaming them in an
interview with steve bannon the defense
is gonna have to
show that this thing was planned and
that a lot of the people involved in the
planning antifa and then even some
right-wing groups were enemies of his
and that they were doing it in order to
hurt him including some right-wing
groups that operate for the
for the lincoln project reminder rudy
would have to say some objectively
verifiable false statement about the
lincoln project this is pretty broad so
far
one of the people involved brought in
right-wing groups that opposed trump he
had the same motivation the anti-people
had and the biggest problems violent
problems were caused by antifa that's
where the shooting took place
i mean that's completely false but you
know rudy is just going to make stuff up
but who's the guy working with the
lincoln project i don't know i don't
know if i can
reveal his name because we have that we
have that from anonymous sources when
steve bannon is laughing at you
you know you're a complete wacko and
you've lost the room here
i'm not sure that this gives rise to
defamation also what damages would the
lincoln project have suffered here if
the lincoln project does follow through
with this this is going to be
performative litigation the kind that i
hate from both sides of the aisle but
anyway subscribe or i'll see
you in court